THEY KEEP TURNING UP ON THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S
INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS AFTER THE
RELEASE OF THE MILA REPORT
SHOWED NO SIGN OF COLLUSION.
G.O.P. LEADERSHIP NOW DEMANDING
ANSWERS ON WHY THE INVESTIGATION
WAS STARTED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND WHEN AND WHAT THE OBAMA TEAM
KNEW REGARDING RUSSIA'S
INTERFERENCE IN THE 2016
ELECTION.
HERE IS SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
>> DID THEY EXONERATE CLINTON
BECAUSE THEY HAD A POLITICAL
BIAS?
DID THEY IGNORE ALL THE FACTS
BECAUSE IF THEY INDICT HER, THEY
KNOW SHE CAN'T BEAT TRUMP AND
THEY WANTED TRUMP TO LOSE?
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, A BACKDOOR WAY OF
SPYING ON TRUMP.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF WORKING
WITH RUSSIA.
THEY JUST USED IT AS AN EXCUSE.
>> Dana: JOHN BRENNAN, HEAD OF
THE CIA OF THE TIME, WENT ON TO
BECOME ONE OF TRUMP'S MOST VOCAL
CRITICS AND HEAVILY PUSH THE
COLLUSION CLAIMS.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT THAT
YESTERDAY.
>> I THINK I SUSPECTED THERE WAS
MORE THAN THERE ACTUALLY WAS.
>> Dana: FORMER DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE JAMES
CLAPPER ON WHETHER HE REGRETS
ATTACKING PRESIDENT TRUMP WHILE
ALSO DEFLECTING RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
IT'S BIG DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S UNWILLINGNESS OR
INABILITY OR WHATEVER TO CALL
OUT THE RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IN
THE ELECTION.
ONE OF PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
OBJECTIVES AND TASKING US TO DO
THAT, REPORT ON THE RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, WAS TO HANDED OFF
TO THE NEXT ADMINISTRATION.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WOULD
HAVE THAT AS A BASIS FOR TAKING
ACTION AGAINST RUSSIA WHICH SORT
OF HASN'T HAPPENED IN SOME WAYS.
>> Dana: COUNSELOR TO THE
PRESIDENT KELLYANNE CONWAY
BLASTING THESE OBAMA OFFICIALS
EARLIER TODAY.
>> THOSE PEOPLE AT THE DOJ AND
FBI AT THE TIME, THEY HAVE
BESMIRCHED THE GOOD REPUTATIONS
AND INTEGRITY OF THE
25000 TO 35000 MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WORK IN THAT DEPARTMENT AND DO
THEIR JOBS HONORABLY.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND THE
PRESIDENT KNEW RUSSIA WAS TRYING
TO INTERFERE AND DID NOTHING
ABOUT IT.
>> Dana: WHEN THE PRESIDENT
WAS ASKED IF THE DECISION TO
INVESTIGATE MATED TO THE
WEST WING OF THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE, HERE'S WHAT HE
SAID.
>> I DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT BUT
I THINK YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, JESSE, DO
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER?
>> Jesse: YES, IT WAS OBAMA.
[LAUGHTER]
ANYTHING ELSE?
I GOT THIS.
THIS WAS NOT AN INTELLIGENCE
FAILURE LIKE A WMD OR 9/11.
THIS WAS AN INTELLIGENT PLOT
THAT WAS FOILED.
WHAT'S SO FUNNY, JUAN?
>> Juan: EVEN GREG SAID
DEEP STATE.
>> Jesse: EVERYONE WAS IN
MOCKING THE DEEP STATE PHRASE
FOR TWO YEARS NOW I'M TOTALLY
VINDICATED.
>> Juan: HOW IS THAT?
>> Jesse: BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
WE WERE LAUGHED AT FOR BEING
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
GUESS WHO THE CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS WERE PAID?
YOUR SIDE.
THIS IS WHAT IT WAS.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATIONS
WEREN'T TRYING TO CATCH RUSSIANS
INTERFERING WITH THE ELECTIONS.
THEY WERE TRYING TO CATCH TRUMP
OFFICIALS COLLUDING WITH
RUSSIANS TO INTERFERE WITH THE
ELECTIONS.
THIS WAS A DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATION THAT USE THE CIA
AND FBI TO ATTACK REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
IT ALL STARTED WITH HILLARY AND
THE DOSSIER.
AS MANY AS FOUR TRUMP OFFICIALS
WERE LEGALLY SURVEILLED AND
CONTACTED BY THE CIA.
THEN WHEN SHE LOST, THEY USED IT
AS AN INSURANCE POLICY TO
REVERSE THE ELECTION RESULTS.
TRUMP CAUGHT WIND OF IT, FIRED
COMEY AND WAS TOTALLY
VINDICATED.
THE ONLY WAY THE MEDIA CAN
VINDICATE THEMSELVES, IF THEY
START PUTTING RESOURCES INTO
INVESTIGATING WHAT WENT WRONG
AND SOME OF TRYING TO BRUSH IT
OFF AND SAY LET'S MOVE ON.
>> Juan: LET ME TELL YOU HOW
DEEP STATE THIS DEEP STATE IS.
THE GHOST OF OBAMA CAME OUT OF
THE LINCOLN BEDROOM AND HE'S THE
ONE THAT FIRE JAMES COMEY.
HE'S THE ONE THAT STARTED THIS
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION AS
OPPOSED TO THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
>> Jesse: THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION BEGAN UNDER
OBAMA'S WATCH.
IT WAS CROOKED FROM THE JUMP.
>> Juan: YOU WOULDN'T HAVE HAD
MUELLER UNLESS TRUMP FIRED
COMEY.
IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH ANY
DEEP STATE.
>> Jesse: HE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD
COMEY INVESTIGATING TRUMP IF IT
WASN'T FOR THE DOSSIER COOKED UP
BY HILLARY.
>> Dana: MORGAN, WHAT CAME
FIRST, THE CHICKEN OR THE EGG?
>> Morgan: HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET IT ANSWERED TODAY.
OUT OF EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE, I
ACTUALLY DISAGREE WITH YOU
SLIGHTLY ON THIS NOT BEING ON
9/11 OR WMD FAILURE.
I THINK IT IS OF THAT LEVEL AND
I SPEAK AS SOMEONE, I'VE BEEN IN
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY SINCE
I WAS 25, 26.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE
TAUGHT AS AN ANALYST WHEN YOU
COME IN IS WHAT WERE THE
FAILURES, THE ANALYTIC FAILURES
THAT HAPPENED LEADING UP TO 9/11
AND WMD AND HOW DID WE MISS IT?
WHAT I HAVE SUSPECTED FOR A LONG
TIME WITH THESE LEADERS OF THE
FBI AND CN -- CIA, THEY FORGOT
THE BASIC ANALYTIC LESSONS THAT
YOU LEARN.
THERE WERE DEFINITELY A LOT OF
RED FLAGS.
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE DOING.
IT WAS THE RUSSIANS THAT WERE
TRYING TO INFILTRATE.
THEY SEE THIS MALIGNED BEHAVIOR
FROM THE RUSSIANS, THEY SEE
RED FLAGS AND BECAUSE OF A LACK
OF FULLY LOOKING AT THE
EVIDENCE, THEY JUMP TO ANALYTIC
CONCLUSIONS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
THAT I THINK ARE ONE OF THE MOST
DAMAGING THINGS THAT ANY OF US
HAVE EVER SEEN IN OUR LIFETIME.
LET'S NOT SUGARCOAT THIS.
THEY ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT OF
TREASON.
WITHOUT HAVING EVIDENCE TO BACK
IT UP.
AS A PERSON WHO SPENT MY LIFE
AND THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY,
IT IS SO DAMNING TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO FAITHFULLY, WHO ARE
PATRIOTS TO DO THIS WORK EVERY
DAY.
BECAUSE OF THESE UNETHICAL
POLITICAL LEADERS.
>> Jesse: MY POINT WAS NOT
THAT THIS WASN'T A HUGE
INTELLIGENCE FAILURE TO THE
LEVEL OF WMD OR 9/11.
I MEAN SAYING THAT THOSE WERE
INNOCENT MISTAKES AND LAPSES.
THIS IS A DEVIOUS PLOT HATCHED
TWO YEARS AGO AND NOW EXPOSED.
>> Juan: NO, IT'S NOT.
>> Dana: I'M GETTING GREG IN
HERE.
SOMETHING LIKE BRENNAN,
SHOULDN'T HE BE HELD TO A HIGHER
STANDARD OF COMMENTARY THAN YOUR
RUN-OF-THE-MILL PUNDIT?
>> Greg: YES.
>> Dana: HE WAS THE CIA
DIRECTOR.
HE SAID OOPS.
>> Greg: IT'S BECAUSE PEOPLE
WERE BELIEVING IN A
HALLUCINATION.
THIS IS WHY I AM THE DEEP STATE
CYNIC WHO WAS NO LONGER A
DEEP STATE SENATE.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THERE
WERE A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO FELT
THAT THEY WERE SO BRIGHT THAT
THEY COULD DO -- THEY COULD
ACTUALLY BE UNDERCOVER, THEY
COULD DO SNEAKY THINGS BECAUSE
THEY WERE SAVING THE WORLD.
IN THEIR HEADS, THEY WERE
SUPERHEROES BUT THEY WERE
ACTUALLY DEEP STATE BECAUSE THEY
WERE DOING THE WRONG THING BUT
THEY DIDN'T THINK THEY WERE
DOING THE WRONG THING.
THE LONG-TERM DAMAGE HERE IN THE
BIG STORY IS THERE'S A LOT OF
DAMAGE BETWEEN PEOPLE AND
NATIONS BECAUSE OF THIS.
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO EXPECTED
NOTHING LESS THAN WAR OVER THIS
OR TAKING OUT A PRESIDENT WHO
MIGHT BE TAKING OUT, REMOVING
THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE MIGHT
BE A RUSSIAN AGENT.
THAT'S HOW FAR THE HALLUCINATION
GOD.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE WHEN THEY LEFT
THE DEEP STATE IT'S BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT THEY WERE DOING RIGHT.
WHEN YOU ARE WEARING A BLACK
CAT, YOU THINK YOU'RE WEARING A
WHITE HAT.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON.
JESSE IS RIGHT, THE DEEP STATE
EXISTED.
THEY JUST DIDN'T KNOW THEY WERE
DEEP STATE.
>> Juan: I DON'T GET IT.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS MUELLER ACTED
HONORABLY.
WAIT A MINUTE.
MUELLER A MOMENT AGO WAS
DEEP STATE.
>> Dana: WHO SAID HE WAS
DEEP STATE?
>> Juan: YOU MISSED WHAT TRUMP
HAD TO SAY ABOUT MUELLER?
MUELLER WAS INVOLVED WITH COMEY.
COMEY WAS INVOLVED IN FORMER
FBI --
WE HAVE GONE FROM TRUMP DOING A
VICTORY LAP TO VINDICTIVE
ACTIONS.
>> Jesse: WE'RE NOT TALKING